What is the dream?
The meaningless fantasy.
You have the apps and mine
is it the moments in which everything
about life seems to be in blissful
harmony.
When a struggles of everyday life don't
seem to exist?
What happens when that dream turns out
to suddenly be nothing more than the
line in the lose Ori Reality?
What happens when our life is suddenly
turned upside down into chaos when we're
two days to even realize we're nearing
rock bottom or when it's been two
lifeless to half men much at all.
When he media comes crashing down and
through our reality and to the Light
House that stands at the center of our
unconscious and which we had trust it to
light us a bath in to the unknown and
what happens when we're the ones who are
directly responsible for this collapse,
carrying the burden of guilt.
Ever presence.
You remind us of our deeds.
Perhaps you lick of paint will wash it
away.
Covering the stains of who we truly are.
Maybe that way we get to move on.
He's back and miracle that something's
off.
He's changed and he's dying because of
me.
It's my fault.
I'm a space or whatever he has faced
before me and him.
But where and how do we start?
Blackwater National Park reported that a
light house was surrounded by something
they termed a shimmer.
Is it a religious event,
an extra terrestrial event,
perhaps a higher dimension,
something so large and skill and alien
and appearance has to be something
external outside of us.
And yet at the same time it feels
strangely familiar,
like something profoundly internal,
hidden behind in ever-growing fill of
illusion,
staying on its edge and observing it
from a distance might feel safe,
but the only real solution is to be
found when we mustered the courage to
venture inside and so we shell and the
unconscious one is unfortunately in the
same situation as an a moonlit
landscape.
All the contents are blurred and merge
into one another and one never knows
exactly what or where anything is or
where one thing begins and ends.
This world within the Dome is the
strangest,
most confusing place.
One could visit and don't know where it
was.
Time,
space and matter merge seamlessly as if
in the dream,
the order and structure of the outside
world don't exist here.
To say one might get lost in this place
would be an understatement,
and yet this is the place we
collectively find ourselves did.
Geomorphologists beyond warning the
physicist without purpose,
the addict,
the terminally ill,
the adulterer all in the state of inner
confusion risking their lives to find
answers,
problems,
only dose that are going through deep
inner instability would find himself
Scott up in.
It's not exactly something you do if
your life is in perfect harmony,
but if the king of this world is chaos,
then beauty is not the only thing one is
bound to find lurking just below the
surface are those primal creatures that
will test our instinctual abilities when
we least expect it.
Okay.
The familiar dream in which to dreamers
pursued by an animal nearly always
indicates that an instinct has been
split off from our consciousness and
ought to be yours trying to be
readmitted and integrated into life.
The more dangerous to behavior of the
animal and the dream.
The more unconscious is the primitive
and instinctual soul.
The dreamer and the more imperative is
its integration into his life.
If some irreparable evil is to be
forestalled facing this dragon head on
is to merge with the primal instincts
that can guide us deeper into this new
world.
Failing to do so can make us stray from
the light and become blinded in the
darkness,
unconscious in Darfur,
a vulnerable to the dangerous that can
emerge into our lives.
At any moment.
We've come upon an abandoned military
base,
a safe haven for those that came before
the memory card is found.
His second revelation reveals itself.
The monsters we believe to be
exclusively external nature dwell
abundantly within our own bodies,
within our souls.
It realization emerges,
am I to veal danger?
Am I nothing bent on self destruction,
right?
Drink well,
we smell and taste stabilize the good
job having marriage
setting,
it will be to admit to one's own
shortcomings,
which we so often tried to hide behind a
mass personality,
denying it would be to disown its
existence within oneself completely.
There was something alive inside that
man.
No,
that was a trick of the light.
When an individual makes an attempt to
see your shadow,
he becomes aware of and often ashamed of
those qualities and impulses he denies
in himself,
but completely see you and other people
such things as egotism,
mental laziness and sloppiness,
unreal fantasy's schemes and plots,
carelessness and cowardice insured all
the little sins about which he might
previously have told himself.
That doesn't matter.
Nobody will notice it,
and in any case,
although people do it too for to deny or
the only way out is to project one's own
monsters on two dose around her.
How could I ever be a monster?
Maybe you or you,
but not me.
For it is I who knows the way and who
will save the world from then nation?
It's unconscious failure or to come to
terms with one's own reality then
becomes nothing more than another
ultimate dead end.
It is only doe sit on some level.
I've made peace with the fact that
spending time in this world is slowly
changing who we are and how we perceive
ourselves.
It's this growing realization that the
tumor of the Shimmer isn't necessarily
caused by something outside of
ourselves,
but perhaps an echo from our own in our
world.
And so the only way to save the world
would to save oneself.
But why would one bot or to go through
such lengths to salvage something that
wasn't even perceive to contain much
value to begin with?
Life does what it wants,
why bought are struggling against its
will and trust wants to face it.
You want to fight it?
I don't think I want to either of those
things.
Only those who truly desire to return
will have the power to we merge.
And so one by one the companions bearish
dissolve and disappear.
And so Lena is the only one left.
Why did they have to succumb to the
darkness and why am I still here where
they really Anya Shepherd,
Josie venturous or do you just
characters every dream fragmented parts
of an unconscious personality seeking to
be integrated onto the body like the
ever continuing cycle of death and
rebirth.
The sign of the oral burrows to dramatic
symbol of the snake eating its own till
40 integration and assimilation of the
opposite of the shadow.
The only way to truly find out what all
of this means is to make one final push
towards the center,
towards the light house.
In this final leg of the journey,
we are already well broken down,
but as we enter into the lighthouse,
we slowly began to realize the toughest
challenge is still in front of us,
hidden in the darkness,
deep beneath the shining light at a
tower in Mandela shaped or puberes
magnificent in its wholeness,
but equally frightening and appearance.
It shows us a mirror out of which a
figure emerges in shock.
We stumble and we run,
or perhaps we don't run at all,
but lose ourselves in complete
confusion.
People call him the cane.
Yeah.
Now I'm not so sure I can try to fight
it,
but it mirrors my every move,
so perhaps I should desire it for self
destruction is ultimately all that
certain.
What is this creature at acts as if my
shadow,
suddenly a face begins to take form you
sudden realization dawns on us.
You May.
If you are mean,
if you are more meat and I am than I am
alive and I can exist no longer.
Okay.
At Baron we finally become fully aware
that this world is not at all alien in
nature,
but a part of her own self that was
hidden away in our unconscious,
desperately trying to be acknowledged.
The only way forward for
Dennis to look oneself directly in the
eye and accepting to shadow as it is
only then can final illuminating
integration be achieved and miss the
hero is the one who conquers the dragon,
not the one who was devoured by it.
Only one who has risks.
The fight with the dragon and it's not
overcome by winds.
The horde the treasurer hard to attain.
He alone has a genuine claim to self
confidence for he has faced a dark
rounds of the self and dare buying has
gained himself.
We now know better.
We truly are.
And if Daryl by dissolved or pathologies
do return to orders there for shown as a
reconciliation of true previously a
strange soles,
both fought and died in one way or
another and both have reemerged as
someone else won a mere shadow of his
former self.
The other more intact strangers but
strangers more attuned to each other
than ever before.
Embracing one another.
So the very first step to start a new.
Okay.
Thank you so much for watching.
If you liked this video and enjoy our
content,
please consider supporting our work on
patron.
We're consider leaving us a one time
donation on paypal.
At this point we cannot rely on ad
revenue alone.
So all of your donations truly help to
sustain a channel and in return you can
get to if our channels stickers.
Also,
we are fairly active on twitter,
so consider following us on there if you
want to stay up to date on the channel
at.
Lastly,
I'd like to think our top patrons,
Itas,
mackers and Kevin and grim.
You guys are awesome.
Thank you so much for your continued
support.
Thank you all for watching everyone.
See you in the next one.